[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
All right. So, what did uh what did you
want to address or did you have a
question or a concern? Yeah. I guess my
first question is like what is like your
main purpose out here? Like what do you
what are you guys really trying to do?
Okay. I'm going to be real with you,
bro. I'm going to be real. I believe
that Islam is false. I believe it has
misled a lot of people, you know, a lot
of Muslims like yourself and people
who've grown up in it, people have been
converted. And so, um, I'm here to show
that. I'm here to expose that that Islam
really is not under scrutiny. If you, if
we really look at it, take a step by
step, Islam is not true. Okay, that's
fair for you to think. Um, why why
Islam? Why not Judaism? Why not why not
talk to agnostics, atheist? We do. I I
just I just talked to an agnostic uh
yesterday. I'm saying why is the sign
and all the flyers here like because
because there's a large the the target
audience you know for this ministries
particularly is the Muslim audias
there's not a lot of Muslim outreach
that we see around here um there's we we
see you know secular outreach like you
know to transgender or atheist whatever
but not that much Islamic outreach so we
took it upon we felt God called us to do
this okay cuz I've seen this I think in
Baloa Park actually it's almost yeah
yeah the exact same No it Is this is
it's the same guy. He actually has the
tent. Oh yeah yeah yeah. See this I
always I'm about a lot and you know that
whole row of like Yeah. All the venues
Islam Muslims the Christians. I always
see them argue in their case. Um how how
do you if you don't mind me asking? How
old are you? I'm 21. 21. And you grew up
as a Muslim? I grew up I left and I came
and then came back to it. All right. So
then so that's good then. So you've
you've kind of you've left in a way and
made your way back, which means that you
have reasons why you chose Islam. Not
simply because you grew up in it anymore
or your parents or family, but you
actually have reasons why you chose
Islam. I don't have like hard solid
evidence reasons, but I have personal
reasons why. So would you you would say
like like personal experiences in a
sense? I mean, so the reason I initially
in a I didn't like explicitly leave, but
I realized I I wasn't considered a
Muslim. I wasn't doing what I should
have been doing for the Quran. And so I
was like, okay, like I was born into
this. I don't have a reason as of right
now as to keep following the faith. Let
me take a step back. Let me like gaze
over everything else, you know? Let me
get like a real bird's eye view. Yeah.
Man, I went back to Islam because
obviously there's a bit of bias. You
know, my parents are Muslim. It's
probably the easiest one to go back to.
It's familiar, you know, it's cultural.
Praying during my when I when I pray and
I make like I ask God for things. I feel
like he was giving me that peace of
mind. You know, obviously there's a lot
of pieces in the Quran I agree with. Not
much I don't agree with. Obviously, I'm
not going to be a perfect Muslim.
There's some stuff I'm not going to do.
Some stuff I find hard to agree with.
But between the three books, the three
monotheistic religions, it was the one I
agree with the most. To be honest, I
didn't really look into the view of any
other religion just because I I can't
bring myself to think that there are
multiple gods. But just I mean, I agree
with you. There are there are not
multiple gods. There's only one true God
and he revealed himself in a particular
way, right? He revealed himself through
the prophets and he said what he who he
was and what he wants from us, right?
And so so this Yeah. through and through
books, right? Through the scriptures.
This is my thing with with Islam, bro.
My biggest thing with Islam is that it
claims to be a continuation of the
prophets, right, from a Adam, Abraham.
What do you mean a continuation? So,
basically that it has the same message
as them, like right the the Quran we
have now is the exact same message Adam
gave. Yes. Exactly. And Jesus. Yes. So,
so that's my I I see that the Quran
makes this claim, right? It even says
over and over that it came, the Quran
came confirming what came before it.
Right? So, it verifies that what came
before it is true. Here's my problem is
that okay, I see that you the Quran says
this. When I go and check what came
before it, like the Torah, the Gospel,
the writings of uh the Zabore, the
Psalms, I see that there's a very very
different message than what the Quran is
sharing. I wouldn't even say it's very
different. I mean, from what I've seen
in Christianity, there's a lot of
similarities. Okay. Like, I would say
surface level, but but the there's core
differences. Core difference is
obviously Jesus Christ is a prophet
versus Jesus Christ is God, all that
stuff. Yeah. So, like with that being
said, if if if what came before is true,
right? And it says that it's the same
thing what came before, obviously,
there's a
miscon, right? So you could either go
the route of it's wrong and it's not
what came before or you could say what
came before was initially which I heard
you say to them that obviously like we
believe that the other books were
changed and
yeah corrupted and corrupted distorted
and so there's that argument for us and
then there's argument for you guys which
is I don't exactly know what do you guys
I mean I have I'm here to learn just as
much as I'm here today not as good as
the set of I know. Yeah, I know. I'm
just going to make it bigger. What do
you guys think? Oh, that's that's
humbling. That's that's pretty good. So,
yeah, I'll tell you. So, what So, the
point that I'm coming from is actually
it's it's from the Quran, right? So,
you're right that the popular narrative
is that, oh, amongst Muslims, the
previous scriptures have been distorted.
So, the original form of those
scriptures good to go. But the corrupted
forms, no, it's a no no. And so, that's
not what the Quran is talking about.
Right? Here's my my retort to that is is
that the Quran never says that the Quran
says that like in Muhammad's time that
it's confirming the scriptures that is
in the hands of the Jews and Christians
that's with them. You know, it says the
ones that came before. No, let let me
show you.
Um let me show you.
So this okay so sir Bakura if we go to
like I actually have this one memorized
good the whole chapter. Yeah, it's in
Arabic. I don't fully understand it,
which Bro, this is like 280. It's 50
pages when it's just Arabic. Oh, so not
it's not really as No, 50 pages is still
long. It's still long. Yeah, you
remember 50 pages. Yeah, I had it
memorized, bro. You're something else,
bro. Okay. Well, I'm going to rely on
you. You're a hi of chapter 2, Sarah
Bakura. Okay, so
um here it is. So in chapter 2 verse 41
surakar 41 and if you want to read the
Arabic that's cool too but I'll read it
in English it says uh and believe in
talking to the Jews specifically that's
the that's the context right oh children
of Israel verse 40 so talking about the
Jews in their Torah right um it says and
believe in what I reveal talking about
the Quran confirming the revelation
which is with you and be not the first
to reject faith therein nor sell my
signs for a small price and fear me and
me alone. Yes. What you're focusing on
here is the confirming what's with you.
What's with you? Yes. So, it's saying
that they currently the scriptures they
currently have with them is true, right?
The translation here is a little bit
different, I have to say. No, it's not.
It's It should say mad like mahum or
something like that.
does mean with you, but it doesn't
necessarily mean it it's more of a
spiritual with you. It's more like it's
within you. No, it's not within you,
bro. It's with you. Like it's you have
it. It's so Wait 41. So this is would be
ayah 41.
this from what I know in Arabic this I
feel obviously there's you also
understand that like most scholars
preach to read the Quran in Arabic right
yeah because that's the way it was
written that's the most
it's the source language yeah it's the
source language and any any language you
translate to another language it's not
going to be one word we can agree on
that right yeah in in most in some cases
it's not going to have a perfect word
for word yeah one word might might be a
whole phrase in English and stuff like
that. Yeah. Yeah. So, from what I know
and I've spoken Arabic my entire life
where this more means it's saying it's
more of like the
book not necessarily we gave you like
I'm saying it's hard to translate but I
would say they did a good job bro mad
and then it says uh makum right so
confirming that which is with you. So
like they let let's read a little bit
further because I think if we read a
little further it'll help out. Um, so
verse 42, "And cover not truth with
falsehood, nor conceal the truth when
you know what it is, right?" So
obviously they have the truth. And he's
saying, "Do not mix it with falsehood
and don't hide it, right? Don't conceal
it." So they so they have to have the
truth in order for them to be able to
conceal it. He's saying that in this
case, the truth is the original book and
it and he's saying do not cover it with
false Yep. Yep. Don't hide Do not. And
then it says, "And and be steadfast in
prayer, give zakab, bow down your heads
with those who bow down." Yeah. Uh verse
44 is good. Do you enjoin right conduct
on the people and forget
yourselves and yet you study the
scripture or I think in this one it may
say recite you recite the scripture if
you read verse 44.
Yeah. Yeah. It's more like recite. Yeah.
Okay. So they are reciting the scripture
they have it. So it's not something
that's like metaphorical or spiritual.
They in this case yeah it does mean
recite the scriptures. Right. So so in
the context we can see that you know
when it says it's confirming what is
with them. It's talking about the
scriptures they have. They're even
reciting it and they're being commanded
do not be hypocrites. Don't hide the
truth. Don't cover it with falsehood.
You have the truth so don't divert from
it. He's saying like as if he's saying
yet you recite the scripture. Yes. In a
sense of like like I'm saying I'm not a
scholar, right? I I think the best
course of action would be bring a
scholar, have him read it out and give
you what it means. Do do you think that
a bit of there's to any book, right?
There's a bit of interp ambiguity
interpretation. Do you do you think this
is this is difficult? I think you don't
think this is clear. I think what this
is saying is what I still told you,
which is that it's not he's not saying
that this book is with them currently.
It literally that's what it translates
to. I'm saying in Arabic it means
something a little bit different. It
doesn't m means with you said it
yourself. But not physically with you.
Not in the sense of So how are they
reciting the scripture if they don't
have it physically with them? As in like
let me read what it says in English
again.
Uh which one? 41 or 44? 41. 41. 4. Okay.
So and believe in what I reveal. So he's
saying he revealed these books. Uh the
Quran specifically. Yes. He's saying you
reveal the Quran
and um confirming the revelation which
is with you,
right? And be not the first to reject
faith therein, nor sell my science for a
small price. Yeah. Yeah, that part's
irrelevant. Semi not to this argument, I
can say.
Okay. So if we if we take it at face
value, it seems pretty clear to me, man,
that the Quran is saying they have their
scriptures. They're even reciting it and
then commands them not to hide them, not
to hide the truth. They have to have it
in order not to in order to not hide it.
They have to have them in order to
recite them. I wish I was more
knowledgeable on this. And obviously,
I'm going to go home. I'm going to look
more into this. This is something I
definitely want to do because I love it
when people point out things. Gives me
something to look at. Gives me something
to try and justify. I love that. And it
makes me more knowledgeable about what I
believe in. And that's always a good
thing. Whoever you are, being more
knowledgeable what you believe in is a
good thing for sure. But from what I
know, from what I've se heard from
scholars I know, there's more, brother.
I'm sure I see all the times.
Well, this actually isn't mine. Um, this
is his. So, he uses this. But I I go off
like memory with with this this like cuz
this topic to me is is probably the most
important for me is is what the Quran
says about the previous scriptures
versus what Muslims say about it. Like
what I'm saying is that the stance that
Muslims take you can't they can't be
conflicting. You got to say what your
book says. If you're if from what you're
seeing you're saying, "Oh, this is what
it's saying and Muslims are saying
something different." Obviously that's
an issue. But what I'm trying to say is
I don't think that that's exactly what
it's trying to say. This is an English
translation. This is an English
translation. You read it in Arabic.
Yeah. And what I'm that's what I'm
trying to tell you in Arabic. The
meaning is more not directly of this
book that you guys currently have. No.
Okay. Look, if you're translating the
Arabic, right? You're you. I'm talking
forget this scholar here. You It says
Madakin, right? Confirming. And then it
says Makum. What's with them, right?
Yeah. So if we're just letting the word
be the word if I was to translate this
from Arabic to English, that's the best
way I could do it as well. Okay. Yeah.
So then it means what it means. It says
that's because there is no word for this
that I can at least that I can think of
that I would use to translate it. You
you can probably use you could probably
use um um to say cuz you're trying to
say w within not physically but maybe
within you spiritually, right? So maybe
you might might say uh uh fee is is like
fe like in fe means in. Yeah. So maybe
maybe instead of makum maybe fe but
obviously you know like we would not
change the words here. I cannot change
the words then don't then don't I'm not
okay. So then if we if we got if we
stick with what it says then we got to
accept that they have the scriptures
presently with them and there the Quran
says that they're true. I don't I don't
think we have to. I think we have to.
We're not an assumption. I don't think
so because like what I'm saying. What if
I show you like four more that say the
same thing? Show me another one. Okay.
Show me another one. I'm actually
curious. Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool. All
right. So, that's chapter 2. There's
more in chapter 2 as well. Let's go to
Let's
see. Let's do verse uh 89.
I do have one question before we go to
the next one. I want to know honestly a
little bit more about why Christianity,
not why not Islam. Sure. We could we
could say why not for a million
different religions. Absolutely. Let's
finish this topic. I'll just show you
the the rest of references and you can
ask me about Christianity. I I I love
that you've been humble enough to deal
with this and humble enough to be like,
"Y'all look at this." I I love that. You
can ask me whatever you want, bro. All
right. Um so, uh we'll do verse 89 and
90. Okay. So, 89. And when there comes
to them a book from Allah confirming
what is with them, although from of old
they had prayed for victory against
those without faith, when there comes to
them that which they have
recognized, they refuse to believe in
it. But the curse of Allah is on those
without faith. Now it says that when
when a book come obviously talking about
the Quran, the book came from Allah
confirming what is with him. Wait, wait,
wait. And when there comes to them a
book from Yeah. Yeah. This this would be
the book from So basically it's saying
now it's it's even given it's
reprimanding them for rejecting the
Quran even though the Quran confirms
what they have and they should have
recognized the Quran. Isn't this how is
it reprimanding them for rejecting the
Quran? Reping them for what you said
again. All right. So B so basically um
so they they prayed for victory from
Allah. Right. And then it says u when
there comes to them that which they have
recognized they refuse to believe in it.
So talking about the Quran the Quran
came other people refuse to believe.
Yes. And and the and the reason why they
recognize it is because it confirms
what's with them. Again this is the same
kind of thing though. It's it's it's not
the Torah or this is still talking about
the Jews, correct? Yes. Yeah. This is I
get this is the exact same wording. Yes,
I would give you the exact same
response. Wow. If it if it says it in
two places. That's what I'm saying is
this will always translate to with them
though. Exactly. But it's not there is
no correct way to translate. This is the
most correct because it gives you the
most close the closest interpretation.
But I wouldn't say this is still the
correct way. So let me ask you this
then. Okay. Uh same kind of the same
lines of the last one with this one.
Notice how it says that when there comes
to them that which they have recognized.
talking about the Quran. Yeah. They
still refuse to believe in it, right?
Yeah. Why? And then it says, "But the
curse of Allah is on those without
faith." So he's cursing them for not
having faith in the Quran as it confirms
what they have. Why would Allah be
reprimanding them if they don't have the
scriptures to recognize the Quran with?
He's saying he gave them the Quran
confirming what and what is with them.
Again, I'm going just like read this as
the way I've interpreted. No, read it as
what it is, brother. in Arabic. This is
how I would this is how I interpret it.
This is how the scholars I know would
interpret. No, that even the guy even is
saying they have it with them. I tab
they say they have it with them. If you
were to read this in English in the way
that it's written here, it's saying I'll
agree with you. It's saying the Quran
came confirming the current Torah they
have and um and then they they should
have recognized it. They refused to
believe in it. So he's saying that
because they refused to believe the
Quran, which is the exact same thing as
the current Torah, they're going to get
punished. Yes, that's what this to say.
Yes. But again, what I'm saying is I
mean, we can't move on from this topic
at least until I cuz this is kind of the
same thing, right? We can I'm I'm just
I'm going to show you similar with them
aspect. Yeah. All right. So, now I'm I'm
going to just show you two more and then
and then we can move to Christianity.
Okay. Yeah. One sec though. I want to
see if I can I don't know if all the
English translates the same,
brother. You know Arabic. I don't care
about the English. Yeah. But like I
wanted like maybe they have a better way
of
um 89. Yeah. 89. Yep. Surah Bakar 89.
Yeah. See like in this this is a a Quran
app I used when a scripture came to them
from God confirming what they already
had in the past. It says had. Yeah. Had.
Yeah. That's that's incorrect because
you you know the Arabic. Yeah. Does it
say what they had in the past or does it
say what's with them? Malcolm. Let me
read this way.
Yeah, Lima kind of does mean can. It
does indicate a past tense. Lima. Lima.
Lima. What? What is the word? Lima.
So, what they have with them? Mahome is
with them. Lima. Mau. Yeah. It's kind of
referencing past almost. No, it's not,
brother. How can you tell me that this
one's wrong and this one's right,
though? Because you're the Arabic
speaker. You can confirm for me if we're
being honest. You're saying this
translation's wrong and this translation
is right. Yes, but this this this app is
like commonly like accepted. No, no.
This it's not the app itself. This is a
particular translation you're using. I I
have the same app, I think. So, what
what translation is this? Um, this is
translation over here. So, it's the
Yeah. So, it gets it wrong. To be
honest, I don't know if
he's like Okay, but we can assume that
if a translation is accepted by most
Muslims, it's what it's agreed upon,
right? No, because again we have you
look this is Yub of Ali's English
translation but remember my my argument
isn't from the English it's I'm glad you
speak Arabic so you can confirm what
it's saying you know so I'm I'm my
authority is the Arabic just like just
like it should be it's the Quran it's
written in Arabic so in in the Arabic it
says what is with them not what they had
used to have how can you say it's what
is with them when many scholars say it's
what was I was saying it wasn't with
them many many scholars don't say that
that many scholars
They look there's translations of I
would say both. You have translations
that say what is with them. There's a
couple that say uh what they had or what
was with them. But those are that's
incorrect of the Arabic. How can we say
you're saying you don't know Arabic? You
do. I trust you. And I'm saying I didn't
agree really with the with them
phrasing. No, you didn't. Yeah. That's
what What do you mean? That's the reason
I've been saying this. No, you I'm
saying it's how I would, but I'm sure
there's a more corre it's not like it's
not a onetoone. It's not the most
correct. I couldn't think of something
more correct. That's why I pulled it up
on my phone to try and see if there was
something that I could jog my memory
like obviously like you know. Okay. So,
let's So, let's do this then. Let me let
me give you uh one more. This is uh
Sarah Maida.
By the way, it says it like in almost
every chapter. Yeah. I mean, this
translation should be consistent. If it
says with them for once, it'll say
wisdom for all. Yeah. But this one is
actually is going to be different. Watch
this, bro. Sure. So, this is going to be
chapter five. Ceremida. We're going to
do verse
47. Okay, we'll do 46 and 47 for
context. All right. So, it says, "And in
their footsteps, we sent Jesus, the son
of Mary, confirming the Torah that had
come before him. We sent him gave him
the gospel." Sorry. Therein was guidance
and light and and confirmation of the
Torah that had come before him, a
guidance and admonition to those who
fear Allah.
So let the people of the gospel judge by
what Allah has revealed in it therein.
If any do fail to judge by what Allah
has revealed, they are those who rebel.
Mhm. So the Quran is saying telling the
people of the gospel in Muhammad's time,
let the people of the gospel judge by
what Allah has revealed therein in the
gospel. Saying let the people of the
gospel judge. Yeah. By what Allah has
revealed therein in the gospel. And if
they don't, they're of those who rebel.
Yeah. So that means that they have to
have the gospel in order for them to
judge by it. But yeah, but in this one I
don't I see I see where you could say
there's a contradiction from this to
them those but I don't see the issue.
No, I I think it's I think they're
they're connected. This one right here
is saying we sent Jesus, the son of
Mary, confirming the Torah that come
before, right? Y So you can agree that
they sent him the gospel which confirmed
the Torah that came before. Yes. It's
affirming that Jesus was given the
gospel. Yeah. Confirming the Torah that
came before. Confirming the Torah that
came before. You can agree in this ay at
least that it's saying that they were
consistent. They should have like it's
saying the the gospel confirmed the
Torah that came before. Correct. Yeah.
They're they're in line together. Yeah.
So you're going to be hear that it
states that they are Yeah. The whole the
whole Quran the whole Quran talks about
how the Quran, the Torah, the Zub and
the the Gospel are all in line with each
other. They were originally in line. So
it's no no not originally. It never says
originally. It it just always talks as
if right here confirming the Torah that
come before him. Uh-huh. Yeah. The
Torah. In this case, he's saying he sent
down Allah sent down the Torah. And if
they made edits or changes or whatever,
it's saying they were confirming the
Torah like that he had given them. Yeah.
No, no, no, brother. The the Torah that
came before Jesus, and by the way, it
actually says, I believe here, right? If
you can read the Arabic of verse
46. the
earth. Yeah. And that means that which
is between his hands, right? So it means
that he hasn't is confirming the Torah
that is between his hands. So I'm saying
the gospel. No, no, no. The gospel is
confirming the Torah that is between his
hands. The gospel between his hands. No,
brother. Look. And uh in their
footsteps, we sent Jesus the son of Mary
confirming the Torah Bay yadei. That is
between his hands. Then it says, "We
sent the gospel. Therein was guidance to
light and a confirmation of the Torah
that had come before him." So the Torah
the the Torah that he's confirming he
presently has ba that is in his hands.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah, I see
what you're saying. So at Jesus's time,
he had a Torah that was
uncorrupted. The Torah that he had was
good. The Torah that come before him,
not the Torah that is Benadei. Remember
Benadei. So the Torah that's between his
hands is good.
Obviously, I can't agree with that. But
you know the Arabic, you can agree. I'm
pretty I'm pretty sure what it's trying
to say. Obviously, I'm not a scholar. I
can't as best as other people can. But I
think it's saying that the Torah that
had come confirming the Torah that in
from the past even but but he had the
Torah, right? He had it to confirm it.
He had to have it, right? Yeah.
Obviously, he had to add it. So that
means that like all the Torah were there
were like any obviously there's slight
differentiations in in different books,
right? But some like I'm sure there's
still preserved or semi-preserved Torah
at this time that we're not completely
The point the point is is that there's
no verse in the Quran that says anything
like that. The Quran never says that
they're partly good. They're partly
confirmed. None of that. It always says
confirming these scriptures as a whole.
like as a whole just that's how it
presents it because I think it's in the
way that God revealed it is what they're
trying to say. Well, it says that they
have it. So look um like for example in
verse 43 look it says but why do they
come to you for decision? This is Allah
talking to Muhammad. Okay, the Jews
tried to come to him to try to escape
the Torah's judgment. Um that's the
context of what the background of what
happened, right? So it says, "But why do
they come to you for decision when they
have the Torah?" Before them, meaning in
their presence. Now, before them isn't
even in the Arabic. I don't know why he
put before them. That's crazy. If we
read verse 43, it doesn't say before
them, right? I think it's how he's
interpreting it. Yeah, that's that's
silliness. So, it says when they have
the Torah, right? So, it says they have
it in Muhammad's time. 43.
Oh, that was wrong.
All right. Um, so why do they come to
you for decision or judgment when they
have the Torah?
I don't know why he says before them. I
feel like you have to take that if
you're going to if you're going to see
all these translations like you're like
you have to assume that translation. You
can't pick and choose. No. No, I'm not.
Dude, again, let me let you know my
point, okay? Cuz I'm not being dishonest
or cherrypicking. My authority when I
read the Quran is the Arabic. So even if
in my Do you understand Arabic? I don't
I don't understand, but I study like
words sometimes. Like I have lexicons
that I use side by side. Um interlinears
that break down words for me. And so I
I'm able to double check, you know. Um,
and so like there's certain like when I
I know that phrases or something don't
exist in the Arabic, when I catch it in
the English translation, I can call it
out. So So couldn't we say that this
English translation isn't that great if
there's mistakes in it? Yeah, it's not
it's not per none of them are perfect,
you know. It's the you know, I I don't I
don't even usually like the use of Ali,
but it's what he had, you know. Um, but
I just know that what the Arabic says, I
know that I can confirm it or whatever,
right? Cuz I've studied it. Yeah. So
that's why when I that's you see how I I
call him out. If he if he adds something
there, I can call it out. Like I'm
calling it out like that's that's not
right. I'm I'm consistent, you know? So
honestly, to be fair, like Quran Arabic
is more like formal Arabic. It's not the
way I speak it. The way I'm I can read
it fully well, but Okay. I don't see it
either to be honest.
Yeah. I don't know why he's adding that
before them in there. It's not there.
But anyway, he goes in and says,
"Therein, right, in the Torah is the com
command of Allah. Yet even after that,
they would turn away for they are not uh
people of faith." So they're hypocrites
basically. So it says they have the
Torah. Why do they come to you,
Muhammad, for a judgment when they have
the Torah if in this case they already
have the Yes. So they have the Torah.
The Christians have the gospel and
Allah's telling them, "Judge by your
gospel, Christians, people of the
gospel, Jews, judge by the uh the Torah.
Stop being
hypocrites. Make sense? I see what
you're saying. Yeah. So that's that's
that's my point. So my just to wrap this
up so you can ask about Christianity.
The point of this is is that your main
argument is they're not in line cuz the
Quran's stating that they're not in
line. Well, the I'm saying that the
Quran claims that they're in line,
right? It claims that it's in line with
the Torah and the Gospel. But when I
read the Torah in the Gospel, it it
shows that Jesus it says Jesus is the
son of God. It says Jesus was crucified.
rose again on the third day and stuff
like that and the Quran obviously
directly goes against that. So if it's
conf it's confirming books that it
contradicts. So if the previous
scriptures are true, you're saying it's
confirming books at the time that the
Quran dropped. Say those books that at
the time the Quran dropped were still
perfect in Yes. Yes. pertaining that's
what you're saying the translations. So
yeah, I'll look more into that for sure.
Yeah. It's it's what we we've we've uh
called it the Islamic dilemma. The
Islamic dilemma goes like this. The
Quran confirms previous scriptures. The
pre the Quran massive contradiction. It
contradicts them is true. And then so
therefore the Quran is false since these
previous scriptures are true and it's
contradicting. It's contradicting. Yeah.
Obviously if if you were to take the
translation that way. If the translation
is that way then then that would be
correct. Yeah. My main argument I can't
articulate it right now low enough. No,
it's all good, brother. I I appreciate
you listening and going through it with
me like you've humbly went through it.
You know what I'm saying? There's no
reason not to. It's it's I mean it's I
think it's much worse to turn a blind
eye to possible arguments than at least
you know look there's nothing to be
lost. There's nothing if I decide oh
yeah you're these are 100% right. You
shed a light on me then then I I I now
agree find something I agree with even
more possibly or now I I reinforce my my
beliefs. You know it's it's one or the
other. There's nothing bad. I love that.
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]